is your face and eyes swollen and puffy
or do you know someone who has a swollen
face or a puffy eyes this is going to be
so easy to fix okay what we're dealing
with is edema swelling it's too much
fluid in the body the fluid is inside
the cells and it's outside the cells in
the interstitial spaces which is the
space around the cells now I know about
this because I had it you can see this
in my earlier videos look at my eyes
swollen eyes puffy face now the problem
is this extra fluid is not just in the
face in the eyes it's in the heart it's
in the liver it's in yourselves it's in
your ankles you could press into the
ankle it leaves a little indentation
that's called pitting edema sometimes in
the lower legs you can see it gives us
shiny appearance where the skin is just
bulging out okay and then you lose the
hair on the bottom of your your lower
legs now it could be because you're on a
low protein diet when you actually go
too low with your protein the fluid
inside your blood vessels can leak out
into the cells and start creating edema
but this is usually not the problem so
I'm not gonna really talk about it now
there's two main types of edema
idiopathic okay and pathogenic
idiopathic means unknown cause so let's
say for example someone has acid EEMA
and they don't have a bad heart they
don't have a bad liver their kidney
shows up normal but they still have
edema and then you have pathogenic this
is the person with cirrhosis and their
liver is literally leaking fluid into a
sac around the gut that it's called the
peritoneum you look on the outside they
look skinny but they have a lot of
retention of fluid in the gut they may
have pitting edema and eat lower ankles
that's one version or you might have a
diabetic that has this huge swollen feet
and their ankles are filled with fluid
sometimes the hand is so filled with
fluid they can't actually even bend it
they can't get their rings off so that
would be pathogenic because the kidney
in the heart and liver are a problem
to the heart if you have congestive
heart failure the fluid backs up into
the tissues as well and of course the
treatment that is given is diuretics
okay
avoiding salt and compression stockings
so let me show you what's really going
on behind this condition it is the high
carbohydrate diet that's right you
guessed it the average American consumes
between 250 to 400 grams of
carbohydrates and I'm not talking about
vegetable carbohydrates I'm talking
about refined grains and sugar each gram
of carbohydrate holds three grams of
water so this carbohydrate is acting as
a sponge in your muscles and your liver
around the tissue
so you're basically waterlogged now as
far as myself what I was consuming is
fruit primarily apples okay I used to
consume a lot of apples with peanut
butter I would take the Honey Crisp
apples which is basically 19 grams of
sugar and I would cut it and I would
have that peanut butter I would have a
snack mid-morning mid-afternoon and
after dinner so that's what I was doing
I was eating good otherwise but I was
doing three meals and three snacks so if
you've been watching my channel you know
the problem with that many meals you're
raising a lot of insulin and I was
getting a lot of sugar so I was 211
pounds so right now I am 180 a lot of
that was fluent okay and you can see it
in my eyes and as soon as I cut up those
apples the fluid came right off very
quickly and of course I only consumed
two meals a day right now first meal
right around
I don't know 1:30 2:00 o'clock sin times
3 and the next meal maybe five or six
what happens in addition to this fluid
retention is you also create a lot of
inflammation and with inflammation
you're also holding a lot more water
next thing is that these this high
carbohydrate diet retains a tremendous
amount of salt
so you're holding salt and with that
you're holding more fluid the other
problem with high carbohydrate diets is
you deplete your potassium reserves so
the more carbohydrate you consume in the
form of refined carbs and sugar you're
depleting your potassium potassium helps
to get rid of the fluid so we have
higher amounts of sodium and low amounts
of potassium and we have an imbalance an
average person needs about 4700
milligrams of potassium now if we look
at all the nutrients in the RDAs
potassium is at the top of the list as
far as the quantity of that specific
nutrient we just need a lot of it okay
like magnesium is like 450 milligrams
vitamin C is like 70 milligrams but we
needed just a ton of potassium now
there's been some other studies that pre
historically that we were consuming
11000 milligrams of potassium and of
course to get your body at those levels
you're gonna have to consume more of
these things called vegetables okay big
salads I pretty much do all of my
vegetables most of my vegetables in one
meal it's a large salad however the
first meal I do consume fermented
vegetables okay so that does add to it
but not in large quantities you do get
potassium from eggs and meats but not as
much as the greens so let me just
explain how simple it is to get rid of
that puffiness in the eyes and the
swollen face all you have to do is bring
your carbs down bring them down below 50
grams or less okay preferably 20 grams
you're going to start to get rid of that
excess fluid pretty quick but in
addition to that also increase your
potassium foods large amounts of
vegetables these two simple things right
here will get rid of the swollen eyes
and the puffy face really fast thanks
for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos